I've gone through things and I don't  wish upon anyone in this room I've had  metal rods pulled out of bone marrow  while I was awake I've had jaw  infections where teeth ready extracted  and I can no longer chew my own food  I have to get up every day and be  showered and cared for physically by  another human being fortunately she's a  gorgeous woman that I married  I get stared at everywhere I go and the  moment people meet me if they don't know  a thing about my resume they  automatically justify the human nature  doesn't think to themselves  it must be so difficult to be that man  if somebody pities me they're wasting  their time because I have chosen a line  of strength